[Musique]
alors bienvenue
directeur de cabaret oui en ce moment
c'est plutôt qu'à ballard et aux jolies
a gelé jolie alors malheureusement que
ça va reprendre le grand moment on prend
les provisions dans son smash à melon
coton tige on sait tous maintenant ce
que c'est un écouvillon et c'est parti
louis va l'insérer dans une des deux
narines de 2 à 4 cm jusqu'à ce que tu
sens une résistance la résistance à
résoudre à jouer les cinq rotations
bah oui cette version wii en d'abord
dans la narine bros tout
n'espérez pas vous rendre chez votre
pharmacien ce matin pour acheter un
autotest leurs déploiements devraient
prendre au minimum plusieurs jours
certaines pharmacies espère les avoir
courant de la semaine prochaine et ou
alors la semaine d'après leur vente a
été autorisé hier par arrêté après une
annonce d'olivier ferrand dans la presse
il allait il a quand même la larme
il a les yeux qui pleurent vous avez un
très grand cerf volant qui coule les
deux jeux et des soeurs voilà les deux
yeux qui pleurent donc c'est donc là lui
vient de mesterrieux dessus donc
j'espère vraiment vraiment qui va être
négatif près de 200 fêtards sur la piste
de danse
un dj aux platines et les bouteilles
servi avec des bougies étincelante une
ambiance de discothèque 30 euros le
ticket d'entrée 20 euros pour le parking
blend et mon frère
la soirée qui s'annonce est juteuse pour
les organisateurs a été interrompue par
les gendarmes
oui sauve-qui-peut combat sauf qu'ils
peuvent parfois
c'est rigolo tout petit peu en fait
quand on quand on s'y attache à poster
ce sauf celui qui peuvent le résultat
est tombé je ne suis pas enceinte
pour aujourd'hui je suis négatif tout va
bien l'auto tests montrent que louis est
négative aucun intérêt aucun appel oui
enfin ça ne vous a pas empêché de vous
resservir pour quelqu'un qui n'aime pas
le sucré salé c'est étonnant mais là je
vais te dire que j'ai pas honte et la
bonne route pour la centrale mais là
pour affiner le chef doit quand j'aurai
fini d'étonner
[Rires]
il ya plus de dérailleur pour réparer
les vélos et la demande était oui ça ne
sera pas pareil le pq avait payé sa
toilette c'est très embêtant il affûte
pâte à papier donc pénurie problème
effectivement vous dites quand j'allais
dans une pièce ça constitue les gens
c'est vrai en gros votre expression au
negro c'est comme ça non mais c'est vrai
faut dire que c'est son jour de chance
ce chinois de la ville de benq n'a pas
échappé à un mais à trois accidents
potentiellement mortel à gauche de
l'image de camions s'entrechoquent
l'arrière du semi remorque passe à moins
d'un mètre du piéton par réflexe
gül et évite ainsi le poteau qui
s'écroule le feu tricolore tombe ensuite
ne le blé sera que légèrement
l'homme se relève en triple miraculé
tout ce que je pensais être des espèces
de clichés sur le métier j'en fais
attention les gens de tourner le dos
fais attention c'est un métier où il ya
des gens ils sont là quand ça va ils
sont pas là moi je pensais que c'était
des phrases de tonton jacky ça mais
c'est des vrais trucs que j'ai
expérimenté avec des humoristes et
animateur télé des producteurs de cinéma
[Musique]
et c'était bizarre c'était toujours si
j'allais y arriver
j'ai des gens qui m'ont tourné le dos et
attention quand tout s'est arrangé qui
ont fait un tour complet sur eux mêmes
et qui sont revenus
donc je connaissais les gens qui
tournait le dos mais ce qu'ils font à
c'est une forme d'être humain qui est
pourri de l'intérieur quoi et au masters
1000 de monte carlo après sa défaite au
premier tour conférence de presse et
réaction du tennisman français je vous
propose de l'écouter sur le match on
voit si rien vraiment ça m'apporte plus
rien tennis d'euros quand on voit les
conditions les truffes a va se retrouver
si c'est c'est d'une tristesse absolue
alors que d'habitude c'est le même temps
la demande
donc franchement rien à [ __ ] je vais
rentrer chez moi vous avez un personnage
qui donne qui ne demande qu'à s'épanouir
et à l'existence russe mère d'une élève
voilà donc je suis très calme
j'ai fait très attention jusque là
d'accord donc ghaoui 2020 alors vous
allez encore dire il parle beaucoup
d'argent mais les 1000 euros pour être à
l'hôtel tranquille je rentre chez moi
entre en scène j'en ai rien à branler
rien à [ __ ] des mots très durs liés en
partie aux mesures sanitaires c'est ce
qu'il dit on s'la catcheur stars à
hollywood et futur président des états
unis
dwayne johnson a fait le buzz ce
week-end sur twitter dans un récent
sondage 46 % des américains se disent
prêts à envoyer au rock à la maison
blanche
dans ce tweet publié samedi l'intéressé
ne dément pas si cela arrivait ce serait
un honneur pour moi de servir le peuple
vous pouvez pas en guerre ce truc
piscine sur cette photo les hommes aussi
son fauteuil entraîné les hommes comme
une exactement ils se reconnaissent à
peine mais est-ce que tu as dû alors que
franchement quand on vous voit là comme
ça y'a pas besoin de photoshop
j'ai l'impression que moi j'y crois à ce
couple et que de l'autre côté je sens
qu'il ya moins de motivation et moins
d'engagement de sa part et pourquoi on
fait une ennemie chaland
et moi ça supporte pas
voilà donc ravi d'or
retrouvez cécile eux
ravi que ce barnum je cherche un risque
maladie
on me dit que plus de sarcasmes ouais il
s'appelle sadek wafi la dernière
création la représentation d'un
regroupement d'oiseaux en plein vol au
moment de la diffusion du reportage on
entend une voix en off commenté l'image
comme ils sont mal à l'aise en retour
plateau car il s'agit du présentateur
laurent bignolas sur les réseaux sociaux
les réactions ont été nombreuses
par contre le pire message attention
machine est choisi répond j'ai fait un
pari sur son compte instagram télématin
a tenu à présenter ses excuses à ça
décoiffe cher ça décoiffe nous vous
présentons de sincères excuses pour ces
mots totalement inapproprié et
involontairement blessants envers vous
et les téléspectateurs
honnêtement j'ai très mal manger rustine
pas vous la vérité je vous fais de la
merde shading je vous le dis alors qu'à
mater samassa poté c'était des saucisses
de merde du chou de merde
une pomme de terre mal cuite c'était
pourri pas débriefé 107 ans je suis pas
là pour ça